i made the really hard decision to not
do the season this year dancing with the
stars i have chosen not to be a part of
this next season of dancing with the
stars sharna burgess and lindsey arnold
are taking off their dancing shoes these
people have spent so much time with on
my family and i have a lot of love for
them the ladies who've been pros on the
show for over 10 years revealed they
won't be returning for season 31
premiering september 19th for the first
time on disney plus
can't wait to watch the stars into a
whole new world playing a big part in
sharna and lindsay's decisions they're
kiddos i was not ready to spend at
minimum 10 hours a day away from zane
sharna and her boo brian austin green
welcomed their baby boy in june
sean is amazing she's an amazing mom i'm
a full-time breastfeeding mama and not
only that i just
i am so in love with being a mum i have
this family in this newborn at home that
i
may never get these moments back
and watching him grow in this bonding
time and i just i've been waiting for
this so long so um
i'm staying in that moment and for
lindsay taking a step back to be a
full-time mama is important to her too
one of the toughest decisions i've ever
had to make in my life if i'm being
honest but life is so different for me
now um i as you all know have a daughter
sage is the best and most important
thing in my whole entire world and
family is truly
the most important thing to me i'm just
so grateful for
the opportunity to be sage's mom i mean
i'm just every single day i wake up i'm
like no this is not my life this is so
amazing lindsay who lives in utah with
her daughter and hubby says there was
another big reason to step away
involving sage becoming a big sister
we're trying to get pregnant we want to
expand our family and that is quite
impossible to do if you are not actually
with your husband but sharna who lives
in la where dancing with the stars films
reveals she isn't completely out of the
picture for the upcoming season but i
will be there in some capacity we're
still talking about that i am at 100
capacity with my body i feel fit i feel
strong i'm so ready to dance i'm about
to go into the gym right now
um and we're going to talk about what
that means and how i can be a part of it
[Music]
you